[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le lundi 28 novembre voici le programme
à mortasien de 14 ans est mort dans la
nuit du 26 au 27 novembre ce week-end
lors d'une rixe à Coignières Djibril le
jeune adolescent a été mortellement
frappé à l'issue d'un gala de MMA le
meurtrier présumé un jeune âgé de 16 ans
s'est rendu à la police une cellule
d'écoute a été mise en place pour les
élèves et le personnel du collège
Pergaud de Maurepas l'établissement où
il était scolarisé nous en parlerons
avec le maire de Coignières Didier
Fisher il y a un nom il a pris la tête
de didactis une société spécialisée dans
le portage salarial le 24 novembre
dernier l'a reçu les insignes de
chevaliers de l'Ordre National du Mérite
pour son engagement envers le tissu
économique et Guillaume cayroux
président de la chambre du traversée de
l'industrie des Yvelines est en plateau
avec nous nous reviendrons sur son
parcours et puis comme chaque lundi nous
terminerons cette émission par une page
sport focus notamment sur le
fonctionnement de la billetterie pour
les Jeux Olympiques avec Tony et tanguet
le président de Paris 2024 nous ferons
le point également sur la Coupe du Monde
féminine de rugby en Nouvelle-Zélande
avec Émilie Boulard et enfin nous
parlerons de tennis et de l'UCI
Champions League c'était ce week-end au
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et un plateau
les journalistes de la rédaction de TV
78 Gabriel Gontier bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde vous allez nous parler de ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines oui et vous en avez parlé en
ouverture de ce journal nous reviendrons
sur le drame qui s'est produit dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche à Coignières
nous parlerons aussi du procès du marché
de Val Fourré qui a débuté aujourd'hui
et qui se tient jusqu'au 1er décembre et
ce sera dans quelques instants avec nous
également Michael el midoro bonsoir vous
allez nous parler de sport exactement on
va parler de la Champions League qui
s'est déroulée au Vélodrome national de
50 c'est dû cyclisme on parlera
également de la présidence de
Jean-Pierre Merillon le président du
district des imminent de football qui va
quitter la présidence ce sera en 2024 on
l'aura avec nous sur ce plateau et
Émilie Boulard aussi la fameuse Émilie
Boulard qui a raillonné lors de la Coupe
du Monde féminine de rugby c'était il y
a quelques semaines en Nouvelle-Zélande
on l'aura avec nous sur ce plateau et ce
sera un second de partir d'émission avec
nous également Patrice carmouz le
directeur de l'information de TV 78
bonsoir juste une précision on va parler
de Guillaume que la Chambre de commerce
des Yvelines et non il est à la tête de
didactique depuis 2004 c'est de commerce
des Yvelines depuis un an c'est ça c'est
juste voilà et justement Guillaume
queyraud bonsoir du coup on disait à
l'instant vous êtes le président de la
Chambre de Commerce et de l'Industrie
des Yvelines et vous avez reçu il y a
quelques jours les insignes de l'Ordre
National du Mérite qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous est-ce que c'était
émouvant pas pour un enfant du la forêt
qui a grandi dans ce beau territoire
c'est plutôt émouvant et c'est une vraie
fierté pour l'ensemble des entrepreneurs
et de tous l'écosystème yvelinois qui se
voient honoré au même titre que moi et
que je souhaite remercier et on
reviendra sur votre parcours dans
quelques instants mais d'abord jetons un
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
sera voilé prévoyez du brouillard sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera à 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles
comptez 4 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le brouillard devrait se
dissiper pour laisser place à quelques
éclaircies au niveau des températures il
fera 8 à 7 degrés en moyenne le point
maintenant sur l'actualité du jour dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gonthier on
commence par ce drame qui est survenu ce
week-end oui après le drame et les fois
et les froid pardon à la suite de la
mort du jeune Djibril l'heure était
aujourd'hui au recueillement et aux
questionnements dans le collège du
garçon à mon repas une cellule d'écoute
a été mis en place ce matin à
destination du personnel mais également
des élèves du collège les premières
heures de cours ont été banalisées pour
apporter soutien et réponses à ceux qui
ont côtoyé de Djibril pour rappel dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche le jeune
homme a été tué après avoir reçu un coup
de marteau une risque qui serait survenu
sur fond de tension entre des jeunes de
Coignières et de Maurepas Yann Lamotte
éducateur spécialisée et organisateur de
la soirée revient avec nous sur le drame
c'est familial il y a du monde 600 620
personnes à peu près dans la salle et
donc à l'issue du dernier combat donc le
speaker prend le micro remercie va pour
me passer le micro pour annoncer pour
que je puisse faire les remerciements et
puis voilà fêter les 25 ans comme il se
doit une personne de l'accueil vient me
chercher de Yann écoute il y a une
bagarre dehors on tire dessus au mortier
donc au départ je pense à pour une
blague on dit un bon moment là c'est
copains pour les 25 ans
il y a un truc on fait une blague
donc je sors sans mallerter quand je
sors en fait mon il y a pas d'affaires
de mortier de bagarre il y a plus
personne il y a juste un enfant qui est
par terre
au sol un enfant qui est blessé en tout
cas il est en pris en charge par les
adultes présents la Croix-Rouge se joint
au
truc et puis voilà après c'est
après c'est l'escalade c'est un enfant
qui qui va pas arrêter de respirer et
qui qu'on va essayer de réanimer à tour
de rôle chacun notre tour on va le
masser jusqu'à ce que les pompiers
prennent le relais et l'enfant va perdre
la vie
hier un jeune homme de 16 ans s'est
rendu avant être l'auteur des coups une
marche blanche pourrait être organisée
dans les jours à venir et nous recevrons
dans cette émission Didier Fisher le
maire de Coignières avec qui nous
reviendrons sur l'effet plus en détail
justice maintenant avec l'ouverture d'un
procès aujourd'hui oui après 7 ans
d'enquête aujourd'hui c'est ouvert au
tribunal judiciaire de Versailles le
procès du marché du Val Fourré de
Mantes-la-Jolie ce procès devrait faire
la lumière sur un système de raquette
présumé sur ce marché le plus important
d'Île-de-France au total c'est plus de 2
millions d'euros qui aurait été
détournés selon l'accusation et blanchi
dans des circuits dans les dans les
émirats notamment jusqu'au 1er décembre
c'est 8 personnes
âgées de 32 à 44 ans qui vont être jugés
parmi eux ex placier Aix employé de la
ville petite main du quartier mais aussi
l'ex élu et mère par intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie Sidi lmer soupçonné
d'avoir fait pression sur une commère
sorte pour qu'elle retire sa plainte les
stations de métro de la le 18 porteront
des noms de villes Yves linoise Gabriel
oui c'est l'initiative d'Île-de-France
mobilité qui invite les habitants à
voter pour choisir le nom des stations
sur la ligne 18 du Paris grand Express
qui sera mis en service à partir de 2030
ce métro permettra de rejoindre
notamment l'aéroport d'Orly en 25
minutes ou encore Versailles chantier en
6 minutes alors parmi les propositions
pour la station Saint-Quentin est vous
aurez le choix entre Guyancourt
aiguilles en cours les savoirs pour la
station satori ce sont les noms satori
et Versailles satori qui ont été retenus
alors pour voter c'est assez simple
Mathilde vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site d'Île-de-France mobilité et on
reste dans les transports pour votre
chiffre du jour oui ce chiffre c'est 21
21 c'est le nombre de lignes qui sont
touchées par la grève sur le réseau
skibus sur les 39 lignes que comporte
l'intégralité du réseau alors les
organisations syndicales des salariés
des cartes Perrier et des cartes pour
Toul annonce un mouvement social d'une
durée illimitée
c'est le manque
on en parlait à l'instant Guillaume
kerou vous êtes le PDG de didactis une
société que vous avez créée il y a 18
ans en 2004 elle a aujourd'hui 1100
salariés vous êtes aussi le président de
la Chambre de Commerce et de l'Industrie
des Yvelines et vous avez été fait
Chevalier de l'Ordre du mérite national
il y a quelques jours depuis un an vous
sillonnez les Yvelines vous allez à la
rencontre des chefs d'entreprise quelle
est leur retour quelles sont leurs
retours aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation qui est depuis un an assez
intense puisque j'ai fait près de 150
déplacements rencontré près de 5000
entrepreneurs dans un département que
j'aime à dire être le troisième
département économique de France que ce
qui m'étonne moi-même en tant que
yvelinois et on est dans un on a dans
une terre d'entrepreneurs une terre de
pionniers une terre d'innovation
et aujourd'hui force est de constater
que les chefs d'entreprise qui sont
majoritairement des petites entreprises
des TPE PME sont frappés par un certain
nombre de crises on a eu la crise
sanitaire la crise énergétique la crise
sur le les matières premières
l'inflation aujourd'hui qui nous
rattrape bref la guerre en Ukraine
jamais jamais depuis quasiment un siècle
les petits chefs d'entreprises ont connu
cette situation y compris y compris
nous-mêmes donc c'est une période qui
est assez compliquée et fort
heureusement les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie qui sont 122 chambres en
France avec 16000 collaborateurs passons
à côté de ces petits chefs d'entreprise
pour leur permettre de
de
d'être accompagné dans cette période qui
est difficile et qui doit permettre en
fait un certain nombre d'opportunité
par rapport à cette période compliquée
que nous traversons mais qui qui est en
même temps une période d'opportunité
pour tous ceux qui puissent qui savent
les saisir
concrètement à ces chefs d'entreprise
première inquiétude première écriture
aujourd'hui on l'a vu bon le manque de
matières premières l'inflation les coûts
de l'énergie les factures ont été
multipliées pour les petits entreprises
par 4 à 6 le recrutement le recrutement
c'est ce qui revient chez 90% des chefs
d'entreprise problématiques de
recrutement ça veut dire une thématique
de formation derrière problématique en
fait d'inadéquation entre l'offre et la
demande c'est à dire qu'on d'un côté on
a des demandeurs et puis de l'autre on a
des offreurs mais qui sont sur des
secteurs complètement différents parce
que encore une fois crise sanitaire
oblige on a accéléré les différentes
transitions et transformations de notre
économie et notamment la transition
numérique qui a bouleversé
la totalité de nos métiers maintenant
beaucoup de métiers de tertaires
tertiaire s'exerce en télétravail et
donc ça veut dire que toutes l'économie
sous-jacentes les transports le logement
les tiers-lieux qui se qui se
développent énormément la façon dont on
dont on va travailler donc on va dans on
va s'alimenter donc on va se soigner
tout est complètement bouleversé depuis
maintenant trois ans et en face de ça on
a tout un tas de d'entreprises
traditionnelles qui peine qui peinent à
recruter mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de
jeunes de jeunes entrepreneurs puisque
aujourd'hui le profil moyen d'un
entrepreneur c'est plutôt un jeune un
jeune de moins de 35 ans plutôt un jeune
un jeune de moins de 35 ans alors on a
toujours les seniors de plus de 50 ans
qui sont qui sont un peu chassés des
entreprises mais on a de plus en plus
une typologie de très jeunes
entrepreneurs et de plus en plus jeunes
c'est à dire c'est quasiment à la sortie
de l'école après le stage ça ça doit
vous plaire moi ça me plaît dans un dans
un territoire où notre chambre de
l'industrie a créé près de 14 écoles
dans tous les métiers de notre économie
du bâtiment qui est quand même un axe
quand on a une économie qui repart la
construction le bâtiment est en avant en
avant en avant-poste et donc après avoir
la toute tout le reste de l'économie qui
doit suivre et malgré toutes ces crises
que vous avez évoqué que vous
votre objectif
prise dans les Yvelines exactement alors
voilà le effectivement on va on va
danser
va être transformée mais que
effectivement on aura de plus en plus
d'entrepreneurs puisqu'on va quasiment
doubler la population d'entrepreneurs
dans les 10 prochaines années donc là il
y a une véritable opportunité à saisir
pour tous ceux qui nous écoutent et qui
nous regardent
et sans sans avoir à innover en allant
dans des métiers qui sont les métiers
des commerces de proximité les métiers
de nos industries
des métiers qui sont exercés à proximité
de chez soi donc là on règle aussi tout
le problème de la décarbonation et alors
avant d'être le président de la Chambre
de Commerce et de l'Industrie des
Yvelines vous avez grandi dans le
quartier du Val Fourré à Mantes-la-Jolie
un quartier qui est cher à vos yeux et
d'ailleurs Patrice karmouz vous avez
rédigé le portrait un résumé de portrait
non c'est vrai que si vous voulez faire
une punchline pour dire Guillaume Kerrou
c'est le patron venu des quartiers quoi
parce que c'est c'est vrai que il a
fondé didactis qui était une entreprise
de portage salarial en 2004 qui qui
voilà plus nous on sent salariés une
vingtaine de de structure aujourd'hui
dans d'autres pays qu'en France
d'ailleurs bah vous n'êtes pas des avec
une cuillère d'argent pour la bouche
comme on dit vous êtes vous êtes de
votre ouvrier votre mère je crois une
militante à la CGT ouvrière également
euh les entreprises linoise notamment
chez notamment chez JC Decaux c'est ça
et puis si en français pour mon père et
donc vous avez grandi à Mantes dans le
quartier de Val Fourré alors pas
seulement parce que vous alliez de temps
en temps à Boinville au Montois
le quartier de la politique de la ville
comme on dit enfin le quartier de Val
Fourré qu'on savait bien et puis la
ruralité c'est peut-être ça qui fait que
vous connaissez assez bien la France et
dire d'un côté bah des quartiers où il y
a 60% de chômage à peu près et puis de
l'autre
de l'autre bah des quartiers où il y a
le désert médicaux enfin un certain la
réalité où il est la France en miniature
la France en miniature absolument alors
vous avez fait des études de sciences
physiques et de sciences d'éducation
vous devez éducateur spécialisé mais
alors déjà au collège il avait il avait
pris en mode entrepreneurial
il avait formé c'est ça vous avez fait
la comparatif vous avez fait une sorte
d'entreprise vous aviez formu une
vingtaine de vendeurs déjà que vous
dirigiez qui et donc la coopérative
était rentable d'ailleurs
financer les voyages de fin d'année de
ceux qui ne pouvaient pas se le payer
social comme toute entreprise
aujourd'hui qui qui finance nos
cotisations et donc vous êtes vous êtes
éducateur spécialisé mais comme vous
aimez par dessus tout votre indépendance
et votre liberté bonjour vous retrouver
au chômage
et vous avez vous avez pas 30 ans vous
allez voir les brocs qui vous disent
rien d'ailleurs vous allez voir vous
connaissez personne vous grattez les
fonds de tiroirs vous trouvez 1000 euros
et c'est avec ça que vous ferez
didactique didactis
voilà et on sait dont on sait maintenant
le le succès alors
Guillaume que c'est un peu un
entrepreneur pas comme les autres
pourquoi parce que vous faites de
l'entreprise vous dites que l'entreprise
est une valeur sociale et vous avez
l'impression aussi qu'il faut créer des
emplois mais qu'il faut aussi créer des
entrepreneurs mais cette envie là vous
avez rédigé cinq livres pour aider les
gens à dire que voilà sauf d'entreprise
c'est pas réservé à quelques-uns
à une élite on pense souvent il faut
faire des grandes écoles pour créer une
belle entreprise et en fait non c'est
apporté de de tout le monde de tout le
monde et c'est ce que vous essayez de de
continuer à faire à la tête de la
Chambre de Commerce et une industrie des
Yvelines puisque comme vous le disiez
votre que c'est de doubler le nombre
d'entrepreneurs dans les Yvelines et de
faire des Yvelines qui est le troisième
département en matière économique le
premier voilà vous avez encore quatre
ambitions
alors moi j'ai une question comme le
disait Patrice vous avez
vous avez d'une entreprise à 48 ans mais
vous avez vous n'avez pas fait de
grandes écoles de commerce d'où vous
vient cette volonté en fait de de
construire et de vouloir toujours plus
je crois que c'est des personnalités en
fait moi gamin j'avais envie d'être
utile et puis j'avais un rêve aussi et
finalement c'est je me suis aperçu
finalement très tard à 30 ans que ce
rêve là en fait c'était un rêve de
liberté et donc d'entreprises
d'entrepreneuriat en fait l'entrepreneur
c'est un aventurier un peu fou souvent
qui correspond pas
aux critères du salariat traditionnel et
son site trouve souvent les trois dans
une entreprise traditionnelle et
finalement voilà mais le problème c'est
qu'on a très peu d'entrepreneurs en
France où c'est 3 pouces 3% 3% de la
population française les entrepreneurs
donc c'est une poignée de gens donc le
temps qu'on ne connaît pas entrepreneur
on ne peut pas savoir de quoi il
retourne et on l'a toujours cette idée
par les médias des un peu déformé par le
prisme des grandes entreprises ou des
entreprises qui se portent bien mais ce
que je dis quand je veux doubler le
nombre d'entrepreneurs dans les Yvelines
c'est pas forcément
on a par exemple dans le département des
îles on a par exemple 83000 au
micro-entrepreneurs si c'est 83000
micro-entrepreneurs sur les 132000
entreprises sont accompagnées et qu'ils
peuvent embaucher un apprenti ou un
salarié Vous voyez on a on a créé 83 000
emplois donc vous voulez pas besoin de
grandes ambitions juste un travail de
fourmis de terrain et de porter ce
message positif vers nos jeunes et vous
voyez dans la qualité d'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a un message vers nos jeunes
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas trop de
d'obstacles quand on veut devenir
entrepreneur on voit que votre parcours
est situé dans bûche
alors effectivement
l'entrepreneuriat vous mettez le doigt
effectivement c'est un parcours
d'obstacles et c'est un sport de haut
niveau et pour lequel il faut
s'entraîner sans cesse s'en relâche mais
donc quand vous êtes dans un
environnement et un écosystème favorable
et bien écoutez on peut surmonter ces
obstacles mais effectivement créer une
entreprise et créer même ça petite
entreprise c'est quelque chose
d'accessible à tout le monde d'un côté
mais en même temps de l'autre c'est pas
un long fleuve tranquille c'est quelque
chose de compliqué mais la liberté n'a
pas de prix et c'est ça je veux dire qui
est intéressant dans dans l'aventure
entrepreneuriale est-ce que vous allez à
la par contre de jeunes dans les lycées
les collèges pour demain je retourne à
trappe demain je retourne à Trappes
justement pour porter cette bonne parole
on va signer et on a la chance de
d'avoir fait un certain nombre de choses
là on va les signer une convention avec
avec l'Éducation nationale parce que moi
j'ai été aussi j'ai été aussi gamin dans
dans des écoles et notamment vous l'avez
cité au Val fourrés ou j'ai passé mon
bac et donc il faut porter cette parole
là auprès de nos jeunes parce que
effectivement le monde de demain c'est
son eau jeunes qui le qui vont le porter
à bout de bras et on le voit que
c'était ce monde change à des vitesses
vous voyez en 3 ans avec la crise
sanitaire comme notre économie c'est
complètement bouleversé imaginez dans 10
ans dans 10 ans on n'est même pas on
peut même pas imaginer les emplois et
les secteurs d'activité qui marcheront
dans 10 ans tout va très très vite et
les et les jeunes nos jeunes sont la
solution à cette économie qui va très
très vite juste un mot peut-être sur
deux projets qui sont importants c'est
le fond de revanche revitalisation et
puis le de 78 78 parce que effectivement
on a on est dans un territoire avec
132000 boîtes je l'ai rappelé 700 700
000 emplois portés par ces entreprises
et donc on a des pépites mais dans tous
les domaines que ce soit l'industrie du
futur avec le les supercalculateurs des
entreprises qui font du quantique c'est
des choses qu'on qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément mais c'est l'avenir c'est
l'avenir de de
l'industrie le métaverse intelligence
artificielle bref cette toute cette
révolution cette quatrième révolution
industrielle portée par ses nouvelles
technologies d'une part d'autre part on
a tous les tous les axes autour de la
bicarbonation donc dans cette dans ce
fond de revitalisation qui vient d'être
signé avec le préfet et je le remercie
la semaine dernière c'est accompagné à
cette transition industrielle un
territoire qui est
fondamentalement l'un des plus
industriels de France mais de France
et c'est par cette industrie qui
représente une faible proportion
finalement de nos entreprises qu'on
arrive à faire vivre toutes l’économie
cervicielle donc c'est à dire que il
faut pas être résigné par parce que
l'industrie recule que toute l'industrie
vaculée est l'industrie de demain pour
certains c'est du cd micro puces c'est
de l'électronique c'est c'est une
industrie qui n'est pas palpable c'est à
dire qu'on ne va plus recréer les usines
qu'on avait hier on va voilà
un petit peu pris par le temps
c'est ce qui permet en fait de c'est
toutes les
amendes qu'on payait les entreprises les
grands entreprises qui ont licenciés et
qui va être réorienté vers celle qui les
petites entreprises
et c'est un très bon dispositif merci
Guillaume que d'être venu en parler en
plateau avec nous on parlait des
collèges il y a quelques instants
direction le collège de Grandchamp à
Poissy notre école faisons-la ensemble
c'est le nom que porte l'initiative
gouvernementale gouvernemental pour
améliorer la réussite et réduire les
inégalités scolaires dans le collège les
grands champs à Poissy des équipes
éducatives se sont concertées pour
proposer des solutions le reportage
réalisé par Régine radesch imaginez des
professeurs en mathématiques et en
technologie qui auraient un objectif
commun qui puisse venir ici avec deux
classes et travailler sur un projet sur
deux heures
ce lieu c'est la fabrique un projet
imaginé par des équipes pédagogiques du
collège les grands champs à Poissy avec
cet espace l'établissement souhaite
innover dans l'apprentissage des élèves
encore au stade de l'idée les équipes
participent au concertation pour l'école
ils espèrent recevoir un financement
pour que ce tir lieu puisse exister tout
le monde aura une participation dans ce
projet les parents d'élèves et les
élèves seront associés mais on est une
équipe on va dire d'une petite dizaine
très mobilisée pour le construire à
partir des retours de tous il faudra que
je compile avec mon équipe tout ce qui a
été exprimé pour pouvoir rendre au 15
janvier une copie claire sur ce que ce
tiers-lieux devrait être cette journée
constitue la première concertation du
collège les grands champs trois autres
phases de dialogues sont prévues pour
mûrir le projet le but de concertation
c'est de parler de parler ensemble non
pas de faire des grands débats sur
l'école mais de parler de son école
son école et de pouvoir discerner des
lignes sur des projets qui sont très
concrets sur ce qui peut amener des
projets intéressants
concordants entre tous et que nous
pourrions financer dans le cadre d'un
fond d'innovation pédagogique le
président de la République a souhaité
mettre en place à l'échelle de
l'académie de Versailles plus de 800
établissements participent à ce type de
concertation
l'objectif recevoir un financement du
fond d'innovation pédagogique doté de
500 millions d'euros
un peu plus dans le cadre de la semaine
dédiée à l'élimination des violences
faites aux femmes Isabelle l'envirome
ministre délégué chargé de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et
Geneviève dariussec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées ce sont
rendus au centre d'habitat la Roseraie à
Carrières-sur-Seine pour la présentation
du dispositif Andy gynéco le reportage
de Céline Charles améliorer l'accès aux
soins gynécologiques pour les femmes en
situation de handicap c'est la mission
que ces données l'agence régionale de
santé
Île-de-France en déployant la démarche
en digynéco ce dispositif expérimental a
été déployée en 2019 au centre d'habitat
la Roseraie géré par l'association API à
Carrières-sur-Seine cette étude en hygi
gynéco comportait trois volets le
premier c'était sur le suivi
gynécologique le deuxième était sur la
vie sexuelle de la femme et le troisième
était sur les violences faites aux
femmes Florence donc qui a pu donc
bénéficier dans des gynécos
elle sait exactement ce que c'est qu'une
violence aujourd'hui parce qu'on lui a
tout expliqué nous avons eu la chance
d'avoir une sage-femme qui a pu
intervenir dans ces trois établissements
à la fois dans le cadre de consultation
individuelle et à la fois également pour
proposer des groupes de parole mixtes
c'est-à-dire hommes femmes groupe de
parole dans lesquelles on peut être
abordés des sujets autour du corps
humain mais également des sujets autour
du consentement de la vie affective au
total 15 femmes du centre ont pu
bénéficier du dispositif enigynéco une
action rendue possible via
l'intervention de sage-femmes libérales
volontaire ils ont pour certaines fait
connaissance pour la première fois avec
ce que c'est qu'une consultation en
gynécologie faire connaissance expliquer
à quoi ça sert de rencontrer un
professionnel de santé expliquer aux
femmes comment fonctionne leur corps et
les pousser tout doucement tout
doucement vers des réflexions un peu
plus poussées sur le consentement sur
leur vie affective et sexuelle Geneviève
Darius sec ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées et Isabelle
l'envirome ministre délégué chargé
notamment de l'égalité des chances ce
sont déplacés jusqu'au centre elles ont
échangé avec les intervenants et
résidant sur l'importance de ce type de
dispositif les femmes sont souvent
invisibilisés invisible mais que les
femmes porteuses de handicap sont encore
plus invisibles il faut que les femmes
porteuses du handicap et les mêmes
droits que les autres femmes il y a deux
fois plus de violences en faire les
femmes handicapées qu'envers les autres
femmes des violences en établissement
des violences à la maison des violences
dans les lieux quelle fréquentent un
dispositif qui vise à être généralisé et
déployés dans toute la France la
Bretagne la Normandie et l'Île-de-France
sont les seules régions à en bénéficier
pour le moment
et on retrouve en visio à distance le
maire de Coignières Didier Fisher
bonsoir bonsoir j'en parlais en tout
début d'émission ce week-end Djibril un
jeune de 14 ans est mort lors d'une
risque dans votre commune alors ma
première question c'est tout simplement
qu'elle a été votre réaction lorsque
vous avez appris ce drame
ça a été un véritable
mourir à 14 ans dans dans des
circonstances pareil c'est même
inimaginable là ça a été vraiment un
moment de d'extrême douleur pour le
maire mais aussi pour la population une
population qui est aujourd'hui choquée
on est une petite ville de 4400
habitants on est quand même pas habitués
à ce genre j'allais dire de fait
malheureusement de faits divers et
surtout de je sais pas si on peut
qualifier cela de meurtre en tous les
cas probablement puisque le parquet la
qualifié en homicide volontaire bien
entendu mais bon il y a une enquête qui
est menée par la police judiciaire
actuelle
on verra exactement quelles sont ces
conclusions de cette enquête mais vous
pouvez être certain que c'est compliqué
c'est difficile j'ai sûrement passé mon
plus mauvais week-end de maire depuis
que je suis élu c'est une évidence vous
avez parlé des habitants de Coignières
il y a quelques instants quelle est leur
état d'esprit et ce qu'ils sont en état
de choc comme vous de nombreux en tous
les cas nombreux habitants sont
aujourd'hui en état de choc c'est c'est
quasiment impensable une chose pareille
dans notre petite ville
il y a beaucoup de tristesse aussi
puis il y a aussi un peu de peur bien
entendu pour nos enfants ce qui est
logique quand on a des enfants qui vont
au collège qui vont à l'école
élémentaire au collège au lycée
vous savez il y a aussi ces craintes
peut-être de représailles donc il y a
quand même là
là une forme de peur qui existe même si
j'allais dire tous les moyens sont mis
en oeuvre et j'ai eu hier soir je leur
remercie encore le préfet qui m'a appelé
pour me garantir que l'État était nos
côtés parce que je dis nos côtés il y a
pas que le maire de Coignières il y a
aussi le maire de Maurepas n'oublions
pas que la victime est mortaisienne
n'est pas cognerienne donc le maire de
Maurepas aussi et dans la même situation
que moi
vis-à-vis de sa population donc le
préfet m'a certifié que l'État est à nos
côtés et que l'on mettrait les moyens
tant que cela sera nécessaire pour
protéger nos populations et
effectivement aujourd'hui on a la crs8
qui est mobilisée la nuit pour assurer
effectivement le calme donc moi
j'appelle vraiment vraiment calme à
l'apaisement
il faut qu'on sorte je dirais de cet
état de choc et surtout que ça ne se
reproduise pas
le maire demeure pas d'ailleurs Grégory
garesti appelle également au calme dans
son tweet
130 policiers vous le disiez ont été
déployés hier soir et le seront
également ce soir pour garder ce calme
vous craignez des représailles
bah écoutez
on peut toujours craindre compte tenu de
la situation bon maintenant
dire j'espère que la raison va revenir
de part et d'autre et que cet acte
irréparable finalement nous permettent
peut-être
d'en finir avec ces
rivalités moi depuis que j'habite
Coignières j'entendais parler
effectivement de ces rivalités entre
le quartier des friches de Maurepas le
quartier enfin la rue des Marchands de
de poignières mais ça avait jamais pris
ces proportions là il y avait eu des
échauffourés ça
depuis au moins depuis une vingtaine
d'années il y a des il y avait ce type
de soucis mais il y a eu des
échauffourés mais ça n'a jamais pris
jamais pris une telle
une telle tournure
dramatique
bon en plus avec avec Grégory on avait
entrepris
je dirais à tout un travail dans nos
communes entre nos communes pour
je dirais à chaque fois ramener
effectivement le plus possible calme
faire en sorte que tout cela s'éteigne
où il était presque parvenu puisque ça
faisait depuis un an et demi que nous
n'avions plus aucun problème depuis un
an et demi on était on était dans on
avait réussi à apaiser vraiment la
situation
les choses allaient vraiment beaucoup
mieux et puis là là vous voyez
ça ça rejaillit alors maintenant c'est
pareil je dis aussi l'enquête n'est pas
terminée est-ce qu'il s'agit
véritablement d'une rixe parce qu'on
voit partout dans la presse que voilà
c'est la rixe c'est la c'est la rivalité
traditionnelle entre deux quartiers de
deux villes différentes
oui peut-être non peut-être aussi parce
que après tout qui nous dit que
finalement
n'était pas particulièrement visé que
c'est simplement une vengeance ou
quelque chose sur une personne plus
particulièrement vous voyez ce que je
veux dire par là bon on
en sait on n'en sait pas assez est-ce
que aujourd'hui est-ce que vous allez
mettre en place de nouvelles mesures de
sécurité suite à ce drame
enfin nouvelle mesure oui bien sûr
aujourd'hui on est dans un mois j'ai
réuni ce matin
une cellule de crise de la coordination
tranquillité publique prévention
sécuritaire
donc dans cette cellule on a
effectivement notre police municipale
les responsables du service jeunesse
sport les animateurs et puis notre
éducateur spécialisée j'avais déjà
voyagé j'avais investi et j'avais
travaillé on avait mis en place
on avait embauché un éducateur
spécialisé pour travailler au contact
des jeunes ce qui ce qui fonctionne moi
je ne désespère pas comment dire je
pense que ce travail là on va le
renforcer on va le poursuivre on va
continuer et alors dans un premier temps
il y a des mesures qu'on a prises qui a
consisté à fermer la maison des jeunes
parce que je ne voudrais pas que des
jeunes
de Coignières soient pris dans cette
maison et se retrouve je dirais en
situation d'être agressé donc pour
l'instant la maison est fermée en
revanche les agents qui
qui travaillent régulièrement eux ont
pour mission d'aller à la rencontre des
jeunes dans dans la ville de renouer le
dialogue d'essayer de faire comprendre
que bah il faut effectivement retrouver
des relations normales on est avec une
jeunesse c'est souvent une jeunesse très
jeune puisqu'on voit bien que la victime
à 14 ans le présumé coupable au moins
qui s'est livré là au commissariat
d'Argenteuil à 16 ans il habite
Coignières on le sait japonais à
Coignières bien entendu
c'est une c'est très jeune c'est très
jeune on a là alors ça dit beaucoup de
choses aussi de sur notre société sur la
violence dans notre société
malheureusement aujourd'hui et nous
sommes confrontés à cela et nous devons
faire face les élus mais aussi les
parents bien entendu
on doit faire face à cette violence on
doit dialoguer on doit travailler nous
on essaye à Coignières de le faire oui
merci Didier Fischer je suis désolé on
va devoir écourter l'entretien
l'entretien
dans des limites précises voilà mais
nous travaillons sur Coignières et nous
travaillons avec Maurepas sur ces
questions-là bien sûr il y a aussi une
cellule d'écoute qui a été mise en place
dans le collège où était scolarisés
Djibril le jeune qui a été tué ce
week-end dans le sport et aussi dans
l'actualité du sport également
[Musique]
je le disais on va parler de sport avec
vous Michael elmidoro vous allez nous
parler notamment des résultats sportifs
on commence tout de suite par l'image de
ce weekend on va prendre la direction du
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour notre image du week-end la
structure 50-oise a accueillie la
troisième étape de Lucie traque
Champions League il y avait du spectacle
dans les tribunes avec plus de 3000
spectateurs mais également sur la piste
avec une victoire de la favorite locale
Mathilde gros elle a pris la tête du
classement du sprint féminin en
s'imposant face à la Colombienne Marta
Baiona on l'écoute marche pas sur l'eau
quand on voit le niveau Kia je pense que
tout le monde est fort c'est juste
pour l'instant ça se passe bien pour moi
voilà après peut-être qu'à Londres ce
sera différent mais je pense que c'est
le travail qui continue voilà on
continue à travailler et laisser pareil
pour les filles donc juste profiter des
moments présents et penser au futur
cette Champions League devrait revenir
l'année prochaine au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines et on continue par
du tennis handisport le comité des
Yvelines basée à Feucherolles organisée
pendant 4 jours le tournoi international
BNP Paris vin will share tornament
c'était le premier tournoi international
de tennis fauteuil programmé dans les
Yvelines il y avait un tableau de 16
joueurs un tableau de 8 jours il y avait
notamment Pauline Déroulède l'une des
joueuses françaises à suivre pendant ce
tournoi et elle s'entraîne dans le 78 au
comité on écoute le bilan des
organisateurs et de Pauline déroulaient
au micro de Grégory cannabis
quand je j'ai su que le comité divine
organisait un premier jour international
pour en faire toute l'année à l'étranger
toujours sympa de voilà de pouvoir jouer
à la maison devant un public sur les
terrains où les mêmes terrains où on
s'entraîne toute l'année donc voilà je
pense que c'est réussi pour un premier
une première édition tout le monde tous
les joueurs sont contents au niveau
sportif le niveau alors il y a disparité
bien sûr de niveau mais le niveau global
est relativement élevé et en termes
d'organisation
je pense qu'on peut être fier de notre
organisation puisque on a un retour très
très positif de l'ensemble des
participants
les résultats sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du comité de tennis des
Yvelines et maintenant on va parler du
championnat de fédéral de rugby 2 matchs
et deux victoires pour nous y Vinois
dans la poule 8 la grosse performance
est à mettre au crédit de plaisir les
plaisirsois se sont imposés 20 à 13 face
à l'heureux dans le choc de cette
division une victoire qui leur permet
d'être premier du classement dans le
second match Versailles à largement
dominé les derniers du classement d'Omo
à domicile le score 57-0 une victoire
qui permet au versaillé d'être à la
septième place la prochaine journée est
programmée le 4 décembre prochain on
continue par du football on va parler de
Versailles Versailles gagne pour la
première de Christ son nouvel entraîneur
sur le banc l'ancien joueur de Lyon à
relancé German Lens l'attaquant vedette
hollandais ça payait puisque Lens
inscrit son premier but sous les
couleurs de Versailles dans les arrêts
de jeu du match face à Villefranche
Beaujolais le score final 2 à 0
Versailles et deuxième du classement
après 13 journées le club est toujours
en course pour bien monté et on continue
par le championnat de National 2 au
stade de Montbauron de Versailles le
Racing Club de France s'est imposé à
deux business sur son terrain dans le
derby face à Poissy dans ce groupe a de
National 2 le Racing a ouvert le score
par heure de vous la Lamb check Tourer
ensuite égalisé pour Poissy c'est Arnold
de vous là qui inscrit un doublé et le
but de la victoire au classement Poissy
et troisième il aura signe et premier
après 11 journées merci Michael ennemie
Doro pour ses résultats sportifs du
week-end on continue à parler de
football mais cette fois-ci avec un
invité oui avec Jean-Pierre me rayon
l'emblématique président du district des
Yvelines va partir en 2024 du comité des
Yvelines du district des Yvelines
Jean-Pierre Mario vous êtes avec nous
sur ce plateau pourquoi avoir pris cette
décision
j'apprécie cette décision il y a déjà
quelques mois
tout à fait c'est ça c'est-à-dire que je
suis je suis élu jusqu'au le mandat se
termine en juin 202
parce que ce sont des Olympiades mais
j'ai décidé de ne pas me représenter
parce que j'ai été j'ai passé de 12 ans
au sein du comité de direction avec
plusieurs postes secrétaire général
vice-président vice-président délégué
etc et puis ensuite bien je me suis fait
aller en 2008 comme président ça fera en
2024 ça fera 4 mandats de 4 ans
c'est-à-dire 16 ans 10 + 16 ça fait
beaucoup je commence à prendre de l'âge
et puis je pense qu'il faut laisser la
place à d'autres je vais pas faire le
mandat le mandat de trop il faut amener
des des gens pour gérer le district dans
l'avenir et donc c'est une décision
murmure réfléchie juste une chose depuis
que je suis élu président chaque fois
qu'une personne nous a rejoint au sein
du comité que ce soit dans la liste dans
l'hélice que j'ai mené ou une personne
ou des personnes qui fallait remplacer
j'ai toujours pris des gens qui avaient
au moins 20 ans de moins que moi donc
c'est je suis dans la dans la suite de
ce j'ai prévu et je m'arrête je
m'arrêterai au mois de juin il faut une
autre vision à votre avis c'est
nécessaire d'avoir une autre vision ah
oui il faut il faut avoir une aide une
autre vision personne ne tire
remplaçable et mes collègues vont me
trouver un remplaçant il y a pas de
souci ils vont s'en occuper j'en doute
pas
très bien se passer ça va vous manquer
d'occuper ce poste oui ça va me manquer
mais bon faut être raisonnable
tout mon temps mais bon je vais pas me
plaindre je l'ai voulu donc tout va bien
non non mais je continuerai d'aller voir
des matchs et puis voilà non mais les
choses sont très bien mais il faut
amener il faut amener des nouvelles
personnes de nouvelles idées une
perception différente des choses des
idées nouvelles je pense que il faut
cela il y a déjà des candidats à votre
succession à côté je n'en sais rien
votre connaissance en tout cas non pas à
ma connaissance mais bon mes collègues
vont sans doute en parler entre eux etc
moi je parle pas de ça c'est pas c'est
pas mon affaire ils sont grands ils vont
prendre des choses en main tout va bien
et les les clubs Versailles les clubs
Yves lillois pardon vont prendre le
moment venu de la bonne décision ils
auront une liste qui sera candidates
avec un bonheur ou une meneuse
d'ailleurs non non les choses vont bien
se passer vous qui avez de l'expérience
quelle qualité il faut pour être
président du district des Yvelines de
football alors ce qu'il faut déjà c'est
écouter les clubs puisque c'est si un
district c'est parce qu'il y a des clubs
et les clubs se sont eux qui qui
choisissent et qui prennent également
qui qui s'expriment auprès de nous nous
avons notre assemblée générale vendredi
mais les clubs ils seront là d'ailleurs
je les invite tous à être présent et il
faut les écouter faut pas forcément
toujours
faire ce qu'il demande parce que nous
sommes aussi dans un système dans lequel
il y a plein de choses qui nous sont
imposées par la fédération dont nous ne
sommes qu'un organe déconcentré mais il
faut être à l'écoute et puis il faut
aussi les autres membres du comité de
direction je ne fais rien tout seul je
fais tout ça avec le comité de direction
avec le bureau et aucune décision
importante n'est prise par mois tout
seul et ça depuis que je suis président
pour revenir sur votre bilan de quoi
vous êtes le plus fier c'est le nombre
de licenciés à 41600 licenciés sans 55
clubs dans les Yvelines ce sont des
chiffres qui vous parlent c'est tout à
fait 10000
alors évidemment c'est pas c'est pas mon
action qui a fait ça c'est sur les clubs
qui qui recrutent les licenciés qui
amènent des des garçons et des filles à
faire à pratiquer le football mais on
les a on a essayé toujours de les de les
accompagner d'accompagner les clubs et
de faire en sorte que les choses se
passent le mieux possible avec le dans
la limite de nos moyens bien entendu
mais pour les accompagner parce qu'avant
tout le foot ne fonctionne que par les
clubs nous sommes là que que pour les
accompagner et alors votre pire souvenir
à l'inverse du meilleur souvenir est-ce
que vous avez un pire souvenir le pire
souvenir je vais dire que c'est quand
tout s'est arrêté il y a en mars 2020
donc véritablement là ça a été un moment
très très compliqué pour nous certes
mais surtout pour les clubs et pour les
licenciers vous avez eu peur que
certains clubs ne se relèvent pas
justement de la crise
dans les clubs ont souffert bien entendu
mais ce qui s'est passé aussi avec la
pandémie c'est que il y a un certain
nombre de personnes des dirigeants des
arbitres par exemple des licenciés enfin
des joueurs aussi qui à cette occasion
fait autre chose le dimanche après-midi
et puis qui continuent à faire autre
chose c'est à dire qu'ils ont trouvé que
finalement il y avait aussi d'autres
choses qu'on pouvait faire le dimanche
après-midi donc on a perdu quelques
arbitres on a perdu quelques dirigeants
on a perdu les joueurs maintenant on est
en train de les rattraper je pense qu'on
va cette année battre notre record du
nombre de licenciés ce dont évidemment
on peut on peut que se réjouir d'avoir
un nombre de licenciés qui augmentent
tout en sachant néanmoins que il faut
avoir l'esprit moi je fais toujours le
rapport entre le nombre de licenciés
divisé par le nombre d'arbitres et le
nombre de licenciés divisé par le nombre
de dirigeants et d'éducateurs et plus
notre nombre de licenciés augmentent et
bien on s'aperçoit que le taux
d'encadrement et le taux en arbitrage
diminue parce que ça n'augmente pas
malheureusement dans les mêmes
proportions
on est en pleine Coupe du Monde votre
avis sur cette équipe de France c'est
quel est l'impact de l'équipe de France
au niveau local sur le district des
Yvelines
l'équipe de France si elle se comporte
bien et c'est le cas et la façon dont
elle se comporte à chaque fois une une
influence sur l'ensemble des licenciés
on peut le remarquer à chaque fois qu'il
y a un constatez un bout à chaque fois
ah oui oui à chaque fois il y a un boom
et là ce que j'espère c'est qu'ils vont
aller plus loin possible parce que ils
ont bien commencé et c'est très bien en
plus le spectacle et remarquable je veux
dire les matchs qu'on voit à la
télévision un il y a le contenu du match
mais il y a aussi la façon dont ils sont
retransmis il y a vraiment de très
belles images qui sont juste avant les
coups d'envoi à chaque but etc vraiment
c'est je trouve que sur le plan
spectacle et sur le plan télévisuel
c'est vraiment réussi nous prévoyez un
bout en janvier après la Coupe du monde
parce que c'est un peu inhabituel par
rapport à la Coupe du monde parce que
pour les pour beaucoup de voire pas pour
certaines catégories la date du 31
janvier est une date limite au-delà de
laquelle on peut plus participer aux
compétitions puisqu'on aura dépassé la
on aura dépassé la moitié de la saison
mais même la façon dont les choses se
passent actuellement déjà là je suis
persuadé que ça donne envie à des
garçons à des filles de jouer au
football
je le rappelle vous serez toujours
président du comité jusqu'en 2024 avant
de laisser votre place on continue cette
page sport à présent Michael en midoro
on va parler des Jeux Olympiques
exactement c'était aujourd'hui sur la
Tour Eiffel les organisateurs ont
présenté ce lundi la campagne de
billetterie officielle pour l'événement
la première phase ouvrira ce premier
décembre et se déroulera jusqu'au 31
janvier 2023 cela prend 3 minutes 14
pour s'inscrire et 13 millions de
billets seront disponibles pour les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 on
écoute Tony stanguay le président de
Paris 2024 au micro de Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude si vous voulez acheter un
billet Paris 84 c'est très simple
d'abord on s'inscrit sur la plateforme
ticket Paris 24.org entre le 1er
décembre et le 31 janvier ensuite on est
tiré au sort et quand on est tiré au
sort on reçoit un mail entre le 15
février et le 15 mars on peut accéder
directement à la plateforme et en temps
réel on voit les billets qui restent
disponibles on peut les acheter on peut
acheter jusqu'à 30 billets et ça c'est
important parce qu'on peut avec ses
proches sa famille pour acheter jusqu'à
30 billets et ensuite partager un grand
moment de sport Nicolas dantnerie
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
nous a rej
oint bonsoir Mathilde vous avez suivi la
Coupe du Monde féminine de rugby c'était
en Nouvelle-Zélande et justement avec
nous Emilie Boulard bonsoir bonsoir vous
avez participé à cette Coupe du Monde de
féminine de rugby et vous êtes revenu il
y a quelques jours de la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors comment ça se
passe votre votre retour en France on se
remet doucement du décalage horaire déjà
et là c'est les vacances donc on profite
d'un peu de repos en famille avec les
proches avant de repartir pour le
championnat à la fin des vacances quel
bilan vous faites de cette coupe du
monde plutôt satisfaite et
individuellement j'ai la chance de faire
l'ensemble des matchs de la compétition
des titulaire sur les sur les six matchs
donc je pense que je pense que déjà je
peux me satisfaire de ça ça a pas été le
cas de tout le monde et collectivement
après bah forcément pareil assez
satisfaite on a réussi à avoir cette
médaille c'est pas l'objectif initial
mais on a réussi à bien terminer cette
compétition et à parvenir les mains
vides et c'était le principal peut-être
la montrer la médaille de bronze
troisième place pour
pour l'équipe de France
alors une troisième place c'est midi
vous avez été éliminé d'un petit point
de mi-finale par les Black fermes sacré
ensuite championne du monde il y a pas
un regret quand même de se dire waouh on
a perdu contre les champions du monde si
si il y en a il y en a forcément surtout
quand on voit le scénario du match mon
père a un point je pense c'est d'autant
plus difficile sachant que en fait à
rien c'était soit nous qui passions soit
elle qui passait ça c'est enfin ça a été
positif pour elle et
malheureux pour nous ça a été très
difficile les jours qui ont suivi
énormément de régler regret pardon
énormément de culpabilité de on se
refait toutes nos actions en se disant
bah si j'avais fait ça peut-être que
peut-être que on aurait pu on aurait pu
passer en finale et je pense en plus que
quand on voit qu'on voit la finale et
quand on voit notre notre match à 3e
place qui avait vraiment une opportunité
pour que pour qu'on remporte ce titre
après on n'a pas pu le faire sur cette
Coupe du Monde on essaiera de le faire
sur les sur les prochaines et j'ai pas
d'autre que l'équipe de France arrivera
à avoir ce titre un jour ou l'autre
à la fin à la fin du match c'était
peut-être la pire des fêtes de votre
carrière ah oui clairement c'était la
pire la plus douloureuse et j'ai eu
énormément de culpabilité moi
personnellement à la fin à la fin du
match c'est ça qui était le plus dur à
gérer et voilà je pense que comme j'ai
dit si on avait perdu 40 à 0 ou si on se
fait vraiment si on avait pris vraiment
un gros score ça aurait été différent et
là ce qui était vraiment difficile
c'était consentait que on pouvait on
pouvait l'avoir le scénario du match il
a été il y a eu énormément de suspense
pendant tout le long et on sentait que
chaque action était était allé difficile
à gérer etc et jusqu'à la fin on a vu
que ce ça a été un match exceptionnel et
ça c'est ça le départ par cette défaite
mais c'est quand même hyper encourageant
et voilà c'était c'était un grand match
de rugby il nous a pas souri mais il
nous sourira les prochaines fois en tout
cas vous avez le sourire
relativise aussi parce que elle a ramené
une coupe une coupe alors on sait que le
rugby c'est un sport collectif mais il y
a des reconnaissances individuelles ça
cette coupe c'est parce que vous avez
été élu meilleur joueuse du match contre
l'Italie du quart de finale contre
l'Italie remporté 39 à 3 et vous avez
notamment fait cette action qu'on va
voir tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors deux minutes de jeu et on relance
déjà de son fond de terrain Émilie
besoin de se rassurer collectivement et
même individuellement on s'était un peu
enfermé offensivement dans dans un jeu
de d'occupation au pied et je pense que
c'est les cercles qu'on se libère et
cette action elle a été le fruit de
cette libération donc elle se soldée en
plus par un essai pour Johanna donc
hyper positif et voilà c'était vraiment
du plaisir de de commencer ce match
comme ça et après il a été plutôt bon
pour pour l'ensemble du collectif donc
c'était c'était top les reconnaissances
individuelles c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on peut on peut le dire que vous en
recevez une parce que en 2021 elle a été
élu vous avez été élu meilleur essai du
monde dans le rugby féminin
oui c'était sur mon premier essai
international ma première sélection
j'avais le trophée du plus bel essai et
là du coup le trophée de la joueuse du
match sur sur le quart de finale de la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors justement vous
parlez de cette première sélection c'est
une première sélection c'était en 2021
là maintenant vous avez 19 sélections
vous avez seulement 22 ans et vous avez
commencé le rugby en 2017 c'est c'est
fou c'est une carrière en accélération
de dingue ouais ça a été assez vite tout
s'est vite enchaînés j'ai eu la chance
de faire des mes premières années de
rugby à des sélections soit soit
intercepteur régional etc qui m'ont
amené à aux élections nationales et
après j'ai fait j'ai intérêt le Pôle
France du coup et j'ai fait les
sélections avec le set de développement
et je pense que c'est cette discipline
qui m'a permis de de progresser
rapidement sur tous les aspects du rugby
et qui m'ont ouvert les portes aussi du
15 derrière pour pour devenir
international à 15 vous avez commencé à
Chilly-Mazarin en 2017 et puis là vous
quittez le cas vous prenez votre envol
direction dans le Sud-Ouest exactement
direction toute la région toulousaine je
m'en vais à Blagnac du coup voir
ce qui se fait de mieux je pense dans le
rugby féminin français actuellement j'ai
passé cinq années extraordinaires à
Chili ils m'ont tout appris clairement
on a on avait une équipe incroyable
voilà je pense qu'il était temps de
quitter le bateau de d'aller voir autre
chose de de se confronter à à meilleur
à plus de concurrence etc je pense que
ça me fera que progresser et j'espère
que ça m'ouvrira les portes de d'encore
de nouvelles sélections à l'avenir on
pense déjà au tournoi des 6 nations 2023
ou on est plus focalisé sur sur le club
là on va se focaliser dans un premier
temps sur le club c'est c'est tout
nouveau pour moi je vais devoir
apprendre au projet de jeu m'intégrer
dans une nouvelle équipe donc j'en
connais pas mal quand même mais c'est
c'est un nouveau départ et après les
performances en club feront
un appel pot également pour pour le
financement donc on va d'abord se
concentrer sur le plateau de télé
en plateau avec nous et on suivra la
suite de votre carrière qui s'annonce
prometteuse
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je tends un petit coup
d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin dans les Yvelines le ciel le sera
voilé prévoyez du brouillard sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dents et Versailles
comptez 4 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le brouillard devrait se
dissiper pour laisser place à quelques
éclaircies au niveau des températures il
fera 8 à 7 degrés en moyenne et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi jusqu'au bout avec nous je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]